well you guys aren't gonna believe this
but a bunch of people are mad at me
because of some stuff that I said I know
it's it's it's kind of shocking to hear
you know I took a position I articulated
a point of view and apparently that
point of view is unpopular who knew and
now a lot of people are angry and and
yelling at me and I know again this is
very shocking to you I know you hear
that you think what no way Matt you're
you're you're such an agreeable and
well-liked guy everybody always agrees
with everything you say there's no way
you get that kind of reaction out of
people I don't believe well I'm sorry to
shatter that image that you have of me
but but here we are so the thing that
got me cancelled this time canceled for
by my count the thirteenth times since
mid-september is that I argued for
banning pornography I argued as I have
in the past I believe probably on this
very show that hardcore porn should be
illegal I argued that in fact you do not
have a god-given natural right to post
your sex videos on a public forum and
you don't have a god-given natural right
to view them I argued that both of those
things are privileges and privileges
that we should not be granted because
the proliferation of hardcore porn is in
joyous to the common good and to be even
more specific it is destroying children
I argued that you're privileged to post
sex videos on the Internet
should not outweigh the need to protect
children from the profound and really
quite measurable harm that exposure to
those videos does to them so that was my
argument and I expressed it in a piece
that I published on The Daily wire on
Friday and in a series of posts on
social media mostly on Twitter and it's
the argument that sparked as they say a
backlash sparked the backlash with lots
and lots of people telling me that I'm
not only wrong for holding their view
but I'm psychotic it's crazy there's
just nothing good that can be said about
it at all many of those people by the
way are conservatives or quote-unquote
come
air quotes really they're libertarians
who don't know that they're libertarians
and because they don't really know
anything about their own ideology but
we'll get back to that we get the back
that Amit so what I want to do today is
lay out my case as clearly as I can and
also address the criticism that I've
received and all I would ask is that you
hear me out
okay give me a chance to explain my
argument and then decide if you agree or
disagree if your first reaction when I
say we should ban porn is to recoil in
horror and to think well that's totally
insane then I would ask that you
especially especially you would just
hear me up and whatever objections you
have in your head right now and I'm sure
you have many I'll probably address them
as we continue and if I don't then you
can always email after show and I'll
address it tomorrow but I think I'll
probably get to it so used to be you
gotta give me a chance because I'm
trying to be as thorough as I can i I'm
gonna spend probably the entire show on
this today because number one I think
it's an interesting topic there are
people complaining on Twitter saying
it's so annoying that you started this
conversation who wants to talk about
this isn't it way more interesting like
what do you else what else are we gonna
talk you want to talk about impeachment
some more isn't this at least
interesting to talk about something
different at least and I want this show
to be my definitive explanation of my
position on this topic which isn't to
say that it will be the definitive
argument for banning porn somebody more
intelligent than me is gonna have to
give the definitive argument but this
will be my definitive argument this will
be you know as thorough as I can be now
why did this come out come up in the
first place well as National Review
reported on Friday a small group of
Republican lawmakers sent a letter
calling for attorney general bar to
enforce obscenity laws as a way it's a
fight hardcore pornography now to be
clear what they're requesting is the
enforcement of obscenity laws that are
already on the books and we'll get back
to that we'll talk more about that a
little bit later on but they're not
calling for new laws to be added to the
books they're saying we already
have these laws let's enforce them
radical idea right let's actually
enforce the laws that are on the books
now personally I would hope that this
would be a first step towards a wider
ranging war on hard hard-core porn
though that's not what the lawmakers are
advocating so I'm taking a a more
extreme position than they are which
again is probably shocking to you at the
very least I think this should be the
beginning of a conversation about the
proliferation of hardcore porn and the
government's role in addressing a
problem but this is not a conversation
that most people want to have now of
course you would expect those on the
political left to react and hard to
resist any restriction or ban on
pornography that's what you expect from
them after all this is the side that
generally supports explicit sex
education for kindergarteners child drag
queens drag queens story our trans kids
and so on they are committed to exposing
children to all manner of sexual
confusion confusion and degeneracy at
younger and younger ages and so you
expect them you know where they're gonna
stand the real shame is that so many
people on the right now
are just as likely to valiantly stand up
for the rights of Internet pimps and
smut peddlers we live now in in a
society where the most extreme and
depraved forms of pornography are
readily accessible to children it seems
to me that if your primary concern when
faced with this epidemic is to protect
the rights of smut peddlers and people
who want to masturbate to things on the
internet like if that's your primer if
that's the main thing if that's the main
issue that you're focused on when it
comes to this topic then I would suggest
that your priorities are out of
alignment and I would also suggest that
if you're a conservative and that's your
main thing you're probably not a
conservative at all actually
yet you know any talk of restriction of
pornography is waved off with slogans
about limited government and
declarations about the ineffectiveness
of prohibition and all of that I agree
that government should be limited I also
agree that government can't go around
prohibiting everything that the
bureaucrats currently comprising it
happen to dislike so I'm on board with
that but I also think there's a role for
the government to play in the porn
problem and I'm going to explain why but
before we do that
quick note from from field of greens
have you ever wondered why so many
Americans are sick unhealthy and
overweight between the food supply and a
sedentary lifestyle Americans are in the
worst shape they've ever been that's why
the team of on staff physicians at
brickHouse nutrition created field of
greens field of greens it's an easy way
for you to add fruits and vegetables to
your daily routine without spending
hours in the produce section hiring a
home chef or do anything like that field
greens is made with real USDA organic
fruits and vegetables it also helps to
boost your immunity using antioxidants
and it assists with digestive help
health that is one scoop delivers a full
serving of fruits and vegetables you
just drop it in a cup of water I usually
have it in a smoothie I had a smoothie
this morning actually with that's how I
usually start my day great way to start
the day and bottom line is this it is
real food it's not extracts you look
better you know feel better go to brick
brick house Walsh calm again this brick
house Walsh
dot-com and get 15% off your first order
just for trying it with the promo code
Walsh that's brick house Walsh dot-com
promo code Walsh all right so my
argument for banning sauce regulating
important really boils down to two
points these aren't the only points in
support of my case but they are the
points that I'm focusing on and they're
the points that I personally find the
most persuasive maybe they're better
points out there these are the ones that
to me make the case number one children
are being severely damaged by the
proliferation of hardcore porn
that's my first argument argument umber
to more broadly the proliferation of
hardcore porn has as I said a
detrimental and injurious effect on the
common good it is contrary to the common
good to allow this to continue I'm gonna
elaborate on both these let's start with
children on average children are first
exposed to hardcore pornography at the
age of 11 if not sooner now remember
what how an average works if the age of
first exposure is on average 11 that
means in order to get that average there
are a whole lot of kids being exposed at
7 8 or 9 this exposure is not neutral in
its impact it certainly is not positive
in its impact I hope I don't need to
explain that it's also not neutral
children are damaged in quantifiable
ways affecting their emotional and
psychological development their
attitudes towards other people and
towards themselves their behavior their
ability to form healthy sexual
relationships in the future that
shouldn't be surprising either
if you think about it you've got you've
got kids prepubescent who have no notion
of human sexuality don't really know
what it is and their first
exposure to human sexuality is smut on
the Internet is-is-is x-rated whatever
disturbing dark thing that they happen
to see when they're on it that's their
first that you know when they're when
they're just at the beginning before
puberty developing you know an
impression of what sexuality is and and
and and and growing into the in you know
they're they're in the formative years
they're beginning their real formative
years of adolescence and it begins with
that so that is the seed planted at the
beginning of their real formative years
of adolescence it's not hard to see how
that's going to grow into something
potentially very troubling studies show
that children exposed to porn are more
likely to become victims of sex abuse
and also that porn may encourage them to
become perpetrators of abuse themselves
children who are exposed to porn as
studies show are traumatized by it they
suffer real trauma now I know that word
trauma has been cheapened by college
kids complaining that they were
traumatized by a ben shapiro speech on
campus I'm not talking about that kind
of trauma I'm talking about real trauma
there is a real thing there's there is a
thing called someone experiencing trauma
and young kids exposed to this they're
traumatized by it porn produces
neurological changes in the brain of a
child in the brain of adults as well we
could see this in brain scans well the
difference between the changes in a
child and an adult are that a child's
brain is still developing and forming
and they're still growing so those
changes could have a more lasting impact
so I think this establishes that porn is
widespread ubiquitous endemic millions
of kids are exposed to it very young
none of that is controversial
that's just a fact and that this
exposure is really harming them
intangible and serious and lasting ways
is there not at a minimum at least a
reason to consider evolve involving the
state in this assault on our children's
minds and bodies should shouldn't we at
least talk about it
by the way for anyone who doubts the
harm that porn does to a child and
honestly I don't know how you a thinking
person could doubt it but if you do I
want you to imagine that's imagine a
child wandered it wanders into a motel
room where a prostitute brings her
clients to engage in their business
exchange
imagine eleven kid eleven ten years old
in the room witnessing this happening
would anyone doubt I mean would anyone
deny that the child will come away
traumatized from that would anyone doubt
that would anyone doubt that that
experience that experience of being in a
motel room watching this happen will
affect him in profound deep bad ways
that will probably reverberate through
his entire life
now here's what I ask what is the
difference between a child watching
exactly that kind of thing happened
through a screen or watching it in
person now in this hypothetical in both
scenarios no one's touching him no one's
interacting with him in any way directly
it's just he's watching something happen
what's the different you put a screen
there and all of a sudden it doesn't
matter all of a sudden the effect is
less why would that be the case does the
screen itself act as a kind of emotional
and psychological barrier that protects
the child no I don't think so you know
you talk about consenting adults
consenting adults may well have the
right to do what they want with each
other in the privacy of their homes but
do they have the right to film it and
then publish it on a forum where
children in elementary school might
easily access it that's the question
and if you say they do have this right
where does this right originate don't
just tell me that someone I have a right
to what do you mean you have a right to
do it says who where where does this
right original does originate from God
you know our our in this country if you
go back to the founding of this country
our philosophical notion of rights is
not that it's an arbitrary thing that
the government gives you it's that its
inherent its intrinsic to your human
nature instilled in us by God so I asked
you did God instill in all humans the
inalienable and sacred right to publish
footage of their orgies on the internet
for everyone to see if God didn't then
from where and what does this right
spring
should consider the possibility that
there is no such right you don't have
that right it is again a privilege that
society can either choose to grant or
not the question is whether the
privilege of adults to post their sexual
escapades online is more important than
that should the privilege of children to
be protected from the psychological and
emotional harm that being exposed to it
causes here's the point no reasonable
person could deny that there's a problem
here and not a small problem
stuff is poisoning our kids that's not
up for debate that's not my opinion it's
a fact it's a reality now once you
acknowledge that reality must you not at
least take seriously the notion that the
state may have a role here
there are plenty of times when wielding
the massive hammer of the state is
inappropriate wrong out of proportion
unjust the tool is abused very often
I'll be the first to say that but
doesn't the collective corruption of
entire generations of children perhaps
warrant bringing down the hammer as it
were it isn't this a time when when
justice calls for that step potentially
now as to my second point the common
good I believe the whole reason the
government exists and this is an
important point we have to establish to
begin with I think when we start talking
about what we think the government
should do and not do we can't really
have an intelligent conversation or even
an intelligible conversation about that
unless everyone involved in the
conversation has some idea of what of
what they think the government is and
and and why it fundamentally exists I
would say and not just me by the way but
I'm going to agree with like Aristotle
and Aquinas and those guys and say that
the government exists to protect and
advance the common good this should not
be controversial but these days a lot of
people especially conservatives are apt
to say no no that's not it government
exists to protect rights because the
common good is subjective and can be
abused and who decides what's good no no
rights are the point I think this kind
of a response is is shallow to be honest
with you and I blame
many things but among them the influence
of libertarianism I think libertarianism
has has helped to create a bunch of
conservatives who think that rights can
be protected apart from any conception
of the good and I was told this many
times over the weekend by conservatives
that rights and what is good are two
completely different things have no
relationship with each other and the
government's only concern is with rights
who cares what's good this is this isn't
just libertarianism this is like radical
libertarianism
has nothing to do with conservatism
historically a concept like rights in a
vacuum is of course far more vague and
carries with it far more capacity for
abuse than a concept like good why do
you think we spend all of our time in
this country arguing over who has a
right to what and whose rights take
precedent and all of that nobody knows
what the hell are right even is so all
these people saying I don't know the
government does they forget about good
that's a vague it's no it's about rights
well what's the right you even know what
it is can you define it if we get a
hundred Americans into a room could we
find agreement between any two of them
about what our rights actually are
meanwhile you know in this country we
discovered the right to murder children
and sixty million have been killed under
the banner of Rights so you talk about
the potential for abuse if we say that
the government is there to protect and
advance the common good what about the
potential for abuse if we put if we put
the good aside and just say it's all
about rights sixty million humans have
been killed from that abuse but to the
extent that we're talking about actual
rights god-given rights inherent human
rights then the whole reason why those
rights should be protected is that it is
good so when you say something like we
must protect rights I asked a follow-up
a very fair follow-up which is why who
cares
don't just insist that the government
should protect rights that's that that's
not that's not even that's not the end
of the discussion because now I'm gonna
say why why should it
who cares about rights why does it
matter and your response eventually we
might go through a few back and forth
but eventually your response is going to
be at bottom well because it's good it's
the right thing to do that's why
because in effect it's good for society
it's good for us it's good for us as
individuals and as a as a country to
have our rights protected
what you're saying is that protecting
rights serves the common good which
means that the common good is more
fundamental more foundational it lies
deeper down closer to the root when I
say the government exists for the common
good I'm not saying that as a
replacement of or in contradiction to
the theory that it exists to protect
rights I'm saying that rights real human
rights serve the common good I can't
believe I have to even explain this but
like I said over the weekend so many
conservatives we're insisting that the
government should not protect the common
good this is these are conservatives and
this is what conservatives have done in
in the last few decades they've taken
their own intellectual history and just
thrown it in the wood chipper without
even realizing they're doing it it
should be shocking that any conservative
would say that the government shouldn't
protect the common good but that's what
they say to effect I had people say oh
that's communist that's communist the
common good is about common this is what
happens we didn't see this is this is
what happens when people they choose a
political ideology without reading any
books they have no idea and now all of a
sudden you know arguments made by
Aquinas and Aristotle are communists
good god the point with hardcore porn is
that it is grievously harmful to the
good it has an egregiously negative
effect on the society there is literally
nothing at all good that comes of it
ever not one good thing has ever come of
it and ever could come of it it only
harms it only destroys it only causes
problems it only hurts people really
hurts them hurts those involved hurts
those exposed hurts those who are not
involved or exposed but are in the
families of those who are involved or
are exposed it's bad for society it's
only bad it's never good it's never
neutral it harms marriages destroys
marriages destroys families destroys
children none of these are bald
assertions on my part this is all backed
by extensive research you can just go
and look at it yourself and I would
encourage you to do that
so when you have something that is very
bad has a very bad effect on people has
nothing to recommend it has no positive
application at all nothing good about it
then you have something that I would
argue at a minimum is a candidate for
regulation restriction prohibition this
is the argument by the way in favor of
making stuff or keeping stuff like
heroin for example illegal some people
think that heroin should be legal
because they say well you know everyone
who uses it for the most part consents
to it it's their choice let them do it
if they want okay and that's true for
the most part but but but heroin it is
so terrible has such a detrimental
effect on people in society and is so
devoid of anything positive or redeeming
that I ask why the hell should we make
it legal I mean this seems like the very
definition of something that shouldn't
be legal it will not help society in any
conceivable way for it to be legal
this is something that cannot help
anyone there is nothing good that comes
of it not everything is about consent
all the time there are also factors like
good verse evil right verse wrong the
these things also must be weighed when
we make laws we have to take that into
account nobody has a god-given right to
heroin and heroin is a noxious poison
that destroys community thus why not
make it illegal I'd say the same thing
about porn so to review porn is toxic to
children toxic to families toxic to
marriages toxic to society has no
redeeming qualities whatsoever and and
therefore it should be banned in a
nutshell that's my argument
so I want to go through some of the
objections to this to this argument
first objection these are just the most
common things I've heard maybe
anticipating some of the things you're
thinking right now first objection this
is crazy you're insane you're an idiot
you should go jump off a cliff I don't
mean to pick low-hanging fruit here but
this is basically the counter-argument
that I've gotten from ninety ninety five
ninety nine percent maybe of everybody
that I've heard from so I guess I have
to address it and I bring it up only to
make one point here if you're a
conservative you should not be shocked
and scandalized by the argument that
hardcore porn is not a human right and
should be regulated or banned I'm not
saying you have to agree I'm not saying
we have to be on the same page with I'm
just saying that the argument I'm making
here is an argument that every
conservative 50 years ago would have at
least taken seriously every single one
if you recoil in horror at the very
thought of regulating or banning point
it's because you have so totally
accepted the left's premise on
pornography and probably on so many
other issues as well you not just
pornography you you have hook line and
sinker you have accepted the left's
cultural arguments and you don't even
know it
you are looking and I don't mean this as
you're acting like a leftist like some
some empty insult I I mean it literally
you are seeing the world through the
eyes of a leftist and you don't even
know it
and that's the case if a classic
conservative argument about obscenity
scandalizes and shocks you
it's not just that can
have abandoned their own positions it's
it's that now conservatives are actually
offended by conservative positions on
things
that's how thoroughly the left has won
the left has won so thoroughly that like
I said on common good I was talking
about common good someone someone told
me that the idea of the common good is
jargon this is a conservative so it's
just jargon the very concept of good is
now jargon
this is relativism this is nihilism and
relativism and it has infiltrated
conservatism in a major way when
conservatives decided that government
should not be used to advance the good
in that when that happened and it wasn't
at one point that it happened but over
the course of decades
but that is when conservatism became
limp shallow and ineffectual also
divorcing itself from its own
intellectual history and that is why the
left always wins because the right has
abdicated has run away has surrendered
my friend Josh hammer who also works at
daily will daily wire writes great
pieces every day he made the point last
night that the write has almost entirely
abandoned moral arguments and arguments
rooted in justice
right has almost completely stopped
making those arguments and seated all of
that to the left the left makes those
arguments all the time and they always
win they always win because nobody
opposes them they're just running up and
down the football field scoring
touchdowns and there's no defense on the
field to stop them they say we should do
this or that because it's right and it's
just and these weak emasculated
conservatives are sitting off in a
corner going oh we don't want to
legislate morality so we're not gonna
chime in here hey guys let's not
legislate morality now we don't want to
do that that's that's wrong we shouldn't
do that and then they try to make all
their arguments based on economy or
something like that or even worse based
on rights divorced from the good and
they lose every damned time because
their arguments are weak and timid and
toothless and grounded in nothing if
you've noticed that you're a
conservative and you always lose every
arguments this is why because your
arguments are terrible and have no
grounding
first objection objection number two in
fact okay let's go to the next objection
I just mentioned it legislate morality
yeah we shouldn't legislate we now I
keep going back this I but I don't mean
to harp on it but just the fact that
conservatives are now saying don't
legislate morality this dumb this stupid
bumper sticker slogan that you hear from
conservatives now I mean it is so
depressing don't let of course we
legislate morality what are you talking
about of course we do everything that is
illegal is illegal because we have
decided that it's wrong so every law we
make every single law we make is based
on a moral conception we can be wrong
okay we have decided in this society
that it would be that it's good in fact
that it would be evil to stop women from
killing their babies and thus it is
legal from the killer babies so we can
be wrong with our moral conceptions but
what I'm what I'm establishing here is
that there is no such thing as not
legislating morality that is a thing
that doesn't exist ever anywhere if a
thing is illegal it is because we have
decided or the government's decided that
it's wrong if something is is not just
wrong but evil moral evil if something
is not morally evil then it shouldn't be
illegal simple as that
there is no morally good thing that
should ever be illegal now there are
morally evil things that shouldn't
necessarily be illegal because you have
taken the consideration many different
factors like how do you enforce it yeah
what what would that entail degrees of
things and you know whose effective you
do weigh all of these things but my
point is the only reason why anything is
ever a candidate for being illegal is
that it's evil
according to at least the people in
power so this don't legislate morality
thing I just wish everyone would stop
saying because when you say that you
reveal that you have no idea of why laws
even exist and yet you have opinions
about laws and I know the response oh no
no it's not about evil it's about it's
about you know things that harm others
should be illegal yes but why should
things that harm others be illegal
because it's wrong to harm others if it
wasn't wrong to harm others then it
should be illegal objection number three
porn is a consensual act between adults
well I've already addressed this it's
not an act between adults it's an act
that adults partake in and then post on
the public on a public forum where kids
can easily access it so this idea that
it's consensual and private it's not
your if you do it in your house and
that's it then yeah it's that's
consensual is private it's there's
nothing else to be said about it but
when you take the stab of recording it
and then putting it on the internet it
is not private anymore
and and it's not in you you are
involving now potentially children who
could access it also how do you know
that porn itself is indeed an act
between consenting adults anyway you
don't the link between the sex
trafficking industry and porn is well
established the porn viewer may assume
that the figures on the screen are
acting consensually but the fact is at
least some of the time they're not
the porn viewer may also assume that the
figures on the screen are adults but
many times they're not the viewer simply
has no way of knowing whether he's
watching the rape of a trafficked woman
or the abuse of a minor he could be he
doesn't know
part of the problem is he doesn't really
care see he's willing to take that risk
as long as he gets his pleasure out of
it so he's looking to get pleasure out
of seeing this thing on the internet and
he knows the Magma's mind that like I
don't know this woman could be drugs
this person could be a minor I don't
know but the most important thing for me
right now is to get what I want out of
it and so it has this desensitizing
effect on the viewer on top of all the
other problems where they get used to
seeing other people as objects that
exist purely for their own enjoyment and
no other reason number serve with
objection for war now this maybe I
should have done number one because this
is the main maybe one of the main things
I hear it's well we don't need the
government to solve this this is up to
the parents I know you just want the
government to ban it or regulate it
because because you're a bad parent
I don't know how many people told me
this weekend that if you simply put
parental locks on your computer you
won't have to worry about it now
that would have been a great argument in
1996 in 1990 if we were living in 1996
if we just went through a time warp
there's some sort of wormhole and we're
living in 1996 again then yeah I pretty
much put a put a parental lock on your
computer and is probably the kid won't
won't won't be able to access it but
that I don't think we're in I'm pretty
sure we're living in 2019 America where
in fact the situation now is that
parents cannot even begin to protect
their children or or can barely begin I
mean they can it does matter so it is a
step that should be taken don't get me
wrong but parents can barely begin to
protect their children from porn simply
by locking down their family computer
putting locks on the phone or not giving
the kid a phone in the first place which
I which I highly recommend my kids don't
have phones but porn is so pervasive now
so widespread that a parent cannot
possibly shield their kid from it
permanently it only takes one friend
with a phone
one friend with a laptop one
unsupervised moment on a computer or a
laptop at school you know how many
parents have told me this Mesa but you
know in many many schools most schools
all schools these days require kids to
have to use computers at school you
don't know how many parents have told me
that that their own kids or kids they
know have access porn at school on these
computers that somehow are not locked
down or the kids know how to bypass the
controls so you could be the best parent
in the world you could be the most
attentive parent the most disciplined
and loving parent
and your twelve-year-old could still
access view and be corrupted by hardcore
internet porn that is the reality of our
current situation so if there's a
solution that does not involve
government I'm all your ears but but
don't tell me the solution is putting
parental locks on phones the problem is
so massive so big and so serious that is
beyond the capacity of any one parent to
solve or even sufficiently address in
the case of their own individual child
the reason governments are instituted
among men is that there are some things
individuals cannot do on their own okay
I mean I if we want to stop an invasion
by a foreign power I can't do that and I
could probably get my some of my friends
together and but we're not gonna do a
great job but that's something that we
need the government to do if we could do
everything on our own then we wouldn't
we would have no government we'd be
living in an anarchist utopia but we're
not there's some things that we cannot
do on our own and that's why we have a
government and what I'm saying is that
fighting the porn epidemic is one of
those things and and nobody has
convinced me otherwise the next
objection well you can't ban porn
because the supreme court found that
it's protected under the First Amendment
okay now even if this were true it
wouldn't change my position you also you
also can't right now ban abortion
because the supreme court discovered in
the Constitution looking through a some
sort of decoder ring with a with a
looking at the invisible ink they
discovered a right to abortion the
Supreme Court can be wrong and has been
wrong many times so my position in
principle doesn't change based on what
the Supreme Court said if I think
something is evil and and should be
illegal and is not protected by the
First Amendment I'm not gonna suddenly
say welp I guess I was wrong because
some people in black robes said so they
they they can be wrong and in this case
I think they are despite what any robed
figure may claim I don't I don't think
that porn is speech having sex on camera
is not speech
speech communicates a discernible
coherent idea there is no idea being
communicated or conveyed by porn it's
just porn it's there to appeal to the
basest parts of us it's not there to
engage us intellectually or make a point
or send a message it's not speech a guy
masturbating on a park bench is not
engaged in speech put a camera in front
of him and livestream it on the internet
and all the sudden its speech narrow
what's
that's insane it doesn't make any sense
I made this point of people said oh
that's crazy that's so dumb a guy
masturbating on a park bench is totally
different from people because you know
people choose to access porn whereas
they wouldn't necessarily choose to to
see the guy on the bench okay but first
of all I'm making a point about the act
itself the act itself if sex or
masturbation is speech when filmed then
it would also be speech when it's not
filmed can you think of any other thing
that is only speech if it's broadcast to
billions of people but it wouldn't be
speech if you just said it or did it in
front of ten people doesn't make any
sense if the act is speech it is speech
no matter if there's a camera there or
not
period so if you're telling me that porn
is speech then you cannot escape the
fact that two people having sex publicly
are engaged in speech now what you might
say is that this is the way
that's bad speech that should be
restricted whereas porn is not
but you see when you make and this is
why you don't want to make that argument
this is why you want to try to pretend
that one is speech and one is and even
though that makes no sense but you don't
want to make that say that you don't
want say okay yeah but that's speech
that should be restricted because now
you've admitted that okay there could be
scenarios where people are doing this
and it should be restricted you don't
want to omit that and also as I've
covered now multiple times children do
not have the capacity to consent and so
the millions of children who access porn
access that content they did not consent
to it unless we're saying now that 11
year olds can consent which I'm sure
this is where this is headed and so if
you're on board if you're one of the
porn defenders you're on board with the
people who are working towards the
towards the the normalization and
legalization of pedophilia because what
you're saying is that 11 year olds can
consent to view porn and if they can
consent to view porn then it's not that
far from saying they can consent to do
the things that are being portrayed in
the porn what I'm saying is I don't
think they can get sent to any of it I
don't think they can cycle I don't think
they have the mental capacity to consent
to any of it so if children cannot
really consent to do to view porn
you put that point on the internet and a
children's child sees it whose fault is
it
it's not the child's
now as it happens though actually the
Supreme Court has not ruled out
regulation or even criminalization of
many forms of point in fact there are
obscenity laws already on the books that
can be enforced could be used to
prosecute hardcore pornographers we
could and that's what started all this I
mean there are laws right now that could
be used also there are steps you could
take the government could take to
heavily regulate disincentive
disincentivize segregate pornography
stuff like for example an opt-in thing
where if you want your service provider
to provide porn to you you got to call
them up and say I want to opt into the
porn and and then the porn will be
relegated to like a you know dot xxx
domain rather than com things like that
now in that that all is is
constitutional we could do all that that
doesn't constitute an all-out ban but as
far as this goes if your if your
response to me is well I don't think we
can do it all up and but let's do this
instead I'm gonna say sure I mean I'm
all I'm all about incremental gains when
it comes to this so that's better than
nothing let's start with that I still
think in principle ultimately our goal
is is is what I've been talking about
but if we want to start here I'm fine I
have no qualms about that let's start
there sure and there aren't and we can
do that the next objection well so you
want to ban porn but not guns you're
such a hypocrite okay how many times
I've heard this which is like accusing
me of being a hypocrite because you
catch me eating a steak after I just got
through explaining that we shouldn't eat
diapers
you say oh so now you think it's okay to
eat things look at you you big hypocrite
you're going around saying don't eat
things and here you are eating something
except that I never said we shouldn't
eat anything I singled out a particular
thing and said we shouldn't eat that and
I had very good reasons for saying it
likewise I never said we shouldn't ban
anything I just said we shouldn't ban
guns
plenty of other things we shouldn't ban
also but guns are protected by the Bill
of Rights
specifically porn is not guns are tools
tool that can be used to protect our
Liberty porn is not guns have many
positive applications porn does not a
gun is a morally neutral object whose
whose dangers or benefits are determined
entirely by the person using it porn on
the on the other hand is morally - based
filth with no redeeming quality and
there's no positive application for it
whatsoever so these are two very
different things and there is no
contradiction at all between saying one
should be ban on the other not Kat 10th
is a Fox News personality she made a
version of this argument to me on
Saturday she was she by the way very
upset with the idea of a regulating or
banning porn so she's a big you know she
just really really really upset her and
she sent a whole bunch of tweets
attacking me for it and just a you know
another great spokesperson for
conservatism here a great great
thoughtful thinker and everything she
said this was her argument she said to
be clear with this logic you're arguing
that anything that isn't suitable for
children should be banned from the
internet oh Lord I know and and this is
someone who gets paid to communicate
ideas and and this is how she interprets
no I didn't say that
just because I'm arguing that one
unsuitable thing should be banned
doesn't mean that I think all unsuitable
things should be banned and I'm not
making the argument I'm not saying it's
unsuitable therefore it should be banned
I'm being much more specific than that
there are many stipulations I am making
here it's it's not as simple as porn is
unsuitable that's not the word that I
would use to describe it I mean it is
that but it's also many other things as
well so documentaries about the killing
field in Cambodia those also are
unsuitable for children
should they be banned from the internet
well what why banned porn but not
educational documentaries well because
there are literally dozens of ways in
which porn and documentaries
can be distinguished as as any
reasonable person understands and
governing is all about drawing these
kinds of distinctions the next argument
oh it's a slippery slope hey what are
you worried that we might slip into
decency is that is that was that what we
could be slipping and sliding into a
world where people are decent what
exactly is the worst-case scenario here
that the anti-porn law may be used
against TV networks that broadcast
obscene content well okay
why should that be such a horrific
outcome they're already a bunch of laws
telling what you know determining what
what TV networks can broadcast is that a
slippery slope I mean you can't turn on
ABC at 8 p.m. on a Tuesday and watch two
people naked having sex is that a
slippery slope are you worried that
we're teetering on the edge of tyranny
because of that but here's the thing
porn is a severely toxic thing that as a
profound and lasting impact on children
and adults that is pervasive and readily
accessible by the click of a button and
that has no positive or neutral
application in other words there's
really nothing else like it I mean for
the most part there isn't anything else
in this category
a slippery slope is when you you know
ban one thing in a certain category but
there are a bunch of other things in
that very same category that are almost
identical to it and now it's okay well
now we're gonna ban all that too so
that's a slippery slope but porn I think
is kind of stands alone everyone sort of
knows what it is and yeah I don't think
anyone's been watching a porn ever and
for a minute been confused about wait is
this a documentary or is this a Martin
Scorsese film no I I think when you look
at porn you know it when you see it - uh
to paraphrase um let's see what else I
think I've covered everything
banning porn would infringe on rights I
already covered this I think many times
you know I that kids CJ Pearson big
following on the right told me that it's
tyranny to stop people from posting
hardcore sex videos on the Internet
tyranny tyranny
I just cannot emphasize enough what a
radically left-wing argument that is
coming now from so-called conservatives
tyranny you're telling me you'd be a
you'd be oppressed and tyrannize if you
weren't able to take a sex video put it
on the internet and as for rights you
know I I would just ask again where do
you think you get this right from to
make porn or watch it
the founders conception of right was
that their inherent to our human nature
and given to us by God so do you think
that this is inherent to our human
nature
if you weren't able to do this would you
be deprived of something that is
essential to your nature as a human
being I don't think it makes it argue
finally I think you know you know what
you know what the real objection is I've
gone through all the objections people
throw at me and I think that pretty much
is all of them maybe there's something
else you can email me if you have it but
finally but I think it really boils down
for most people to well I don't want
porn banned because I personally enjoy
it and I think most people they make
other arguments but that's really what
their argument is and at least if you
came out and just said that it'd be
honest and I wish more people would
because that's the one thing that you
notice when you talk about this issue
people get so defensive and so angry
like it shouldn't make you angry okay
it's I'm at the very least if I'm
talking about hardcore pornography and
and you know me insulting or attacking
hardcore porn shouldn't make you angry
and if it does then I think that's a
really good indication that you are far
too attached to this and addicted to it
or you have a severe compulsion to it
which really only proves my point
even more it proves how insidious this
stuff is and what a toxic effect it has
on people and on society and so
ironically most of the people who've
been coming after me about this are
accidentally proving my point all the
way by reacting like Gollum when the
ring is taking front taken from him you
know they they're only showing that you
know this this this is why this is what
it does to you all right so there's my
there's my argument and I will invite
you to if
you've listened to all of us by now I
would invite you to do your best to tear
it apart and send me emails I think it's
an important conversation heavily so I'm
glad at at the very least that we're
having the conversation and as I said at
the top I think maybe we can agree that
even if you don't it's an important
conversation maybe it's a good change of
pace from talking about impeachment all
the time all right we'll leave it there
thanks everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there